- Il y a un des mes chums qui a
disparu. Il a une roulotte au
lac Bastien. Vous ne l'auriez
pas vu passer, quelqu'un?NoNoNo.
- Luc Senay, vous êtes un homme
comblé par ce qu'on peut vous
voir partout à la télévision,
dans "5e rang", "Chouchou",
"Le bo, , , , "L'oeil
du cyclone", "Ma mère",
j'en passe. J'ai un peu
l'impression que vous vivez
votre âge d'or. Est-ce que c'est
un peu votre impression aussi?Cr
et metteur en scène
- Bien, je dirais que oui,
mais c'est surtout que
je me comparerai peut-être
a a a abeille qui butine plein
de fleurs. Alors, je suis
sur toutes sortes d'affaires
qui me permettent d'aller
chchchcher du miel un peu parto.
Le mardi, c'est le pâté
chinois. Le poulet, c'estlelele.
Moi, c'est de vivre
des expériences. Parce que,
t'sais... d'abord, je ne suis
pas carriériste. Si j'avais
voulu être carriériste,
je serais resté animateur parce
que j'ai été animateur de quiz
dans ma vie, mais je serais
resté anim J J J Je serais
beaucoup plus riche que ce que
je suis là. Alors moi, ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de jouer,
puis de vivre des trucs
différents.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Retour en arrière...
- Oui.
- Vous avez été refusé quatre
fois à llelelele nationale
de théâtre.
- Oui.
- Vous avez suivi des cours
à l'UQAM quand même.
- Oui.
-  q q q que le mot persévérance
est le mot-clé dans votre
carrière?
- Je penserais que oui. Oui.
(rires)
Oui parce que les gens, par
exemple, avec qui j'didididié
à l'UQAM... il y avait des gens
qui avaient du talent, admettons
comme moi, puis il y avait
des gens qui avaient beaucoup
plus de talent, ils en avaient
comme ça. Puis, j'ai juste été
chanceux dans la vie, puis...
oui, j'ai persisté.
J'ai persisté. Oui. Passé quatre
auditions à l'école nationale,
il frsrsrsrsister un petit peu.
(rires)
- Vous êtes né à Granby,
se-i-i-i-il que votre mère
ne voulait rien savoir
de vos rêves de devenir
comédien, là.MaMaMaMa mère, elle
j'étudiais en théâtre quand
j'ai eu presque fini d'étudier
en théâtre. J'y ai caché
ça tout le long. Quanddidididit
à ma mère que c'était ça que
je faisais, elle ne m'a pas
parlé pendant un an et demi.
- Un an et demi!
- Et ça a été très difficile,
parce qu'il faququququ'elle
avale quelque chose qui n'avait
pas de bon sens.
Ah bien, la belle grande fille
de mon chum Serge.
- On a parlé de Luc Senay,
le perntntntnt. Je veux parler
de Luc Senay, le courageux.
Bien oui parce que dans
"Faits divers", vous avez joué
un propriétaire de camping
de nudiste.
- Ah! Oui!
- Et dans "Ladies night",
1000 représentations,
on vous voit dans votre plus
simple appareil.
- Oui.
- Comment avez-vous vaincu
votre gêne?- - - - Moi, je n'air
par rapport à ça. Si...
et je m'explique, parce qu'il
n'y avait pas d'actes sexuels.
S'il y en avait eu, là, j'aurais
peut-être eu une retenue,
une gêne, pas àe e e e avec...
même si c'est Chantal,
je ne suis pas sûr...
je n'aurais pas été bien.
Retenons le mot d'ordre :
je n'ai pas de pudeur.
(rires)
Nommez un type de revue dont
il est plus agréable de regarder
les images que de lire
les articles.
- Il y a 30 ans, presque
jour pour jour, vous animiez
pour la toute première fois
"La Guerre des clans". On
voyait faire le grand écart,
la split!
- Oui.
- Avec le recul, c'était
une bonne idée d'animer
"La Guerre des clans"?
Parcçaçaçaça vous a vraiment
collé à la peau.
- Ah! Ça m'a... Ça été...
ça été mquququque. Ça été
une expérience extraordinaire,
où je pouvais rallier,
par exemple, ce que je vivais
avec la Ligue nationale
ovovovovisation, où...
et le quiz. Ça a de l'air
de deux mondes étranges.
Alors, en impro, ce qu'on dit
c'est que tu es dans le regard.
De l'autre parce que je vais
lire dans le regard de l'autre
quand j'improvise. Quand on se
tourne cerererer à improviser,
je n'ai aucune idée de ce que
l'autre a dans sa tête.
Puis l'autre n'a aucune idée
de ce que j'ai dans la mienne.
Mais si on se regarde dans
les yeux, je fais... je sais
tout de suite : "OK, elle ou
il a une idée. J'en ai une.
Oh! Elle a peur, il a peur."
Et ça, j'ai appliqué ça
à "La Guerre des clans".
Si bien que, pour chaque
concurrent et concurrente qui
sont venus, je les ai toujours
regardés dans les yeux
et je voyais si il ou elles
étaient bien ou ils n'étaien
pas bien. Donc, c'était
nourrissant, c'est-à-dire que
je ne suis pas juste en train
de poser des questions,
déchiffrer ça au tableau,
ça allait plus loin que ça.
- Alors, la question du public :
êtes-vous encore capable
de faire la split?
- Oui, mais je ne me relève
plus.
(rires)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je termine là-dessus,
Luc Senay, pour vos 65 ans,
c'est très bientôt,
dans quelques semaines,
vous avez vendu votre maison
à Granby, et avec un concept
d'émission assez particulier,
vous allez partir en van,
en VR pour faire le
de l'Amérique. Ça ne vous fait
pas un peu peur de ne plus avoir
de maisons et de juste être
dans un VR?
- Ah non, non, non, pas du tout!
Pas du tout. Non, non. Puis
c'était magnifique, on était
dans lagagagagne de Shefford.
Puis, on s'est défait de ça.
On avait vécu 22 ans là.
Puis là, ce qui est difficile
pour nous, c'est que... bien,
isisisis ça puis de moins
en moins, c'est qu'on avait
un entrepôt avec toutes
nos affaires. Puis là, on se
défait de tout. On donne tout.
Il va nous rester
quatre assiettes,
quatre fourchettes, quatre
cuillères, quatre tasses...
le minimum. Ça fais que
c'est comme ça qu'on peut vivre,
dans la simplicité. On avait
un autre VR qu'on s'est défait.
Et on a pensé celui-là en
fonction d'en faire un mini
studio qui nous permettrait
de faire notre projet comme tel.
C'est 11:11 Media, donc on va
faire ça ensemble, les trois,
notre chatte puis moi. Puis,
bien on verra où est-ce que ça
nous mène.
- Luc Senay, la prochaine année
s'annonce fascinante pour vous.
Merci beaucoup.
(rires)
- C'est moi qui vous remercie.
♪ ♪